foreign
what is the premise of the podcast all
in is a podcast with four friends who
are all capital allocators in other
words like venture capitalist investors
and business Builders and I guess in all
cases four folks who are 50 years old
with 30 years of business experience
each so that's about over 120 years
building businesses or investing in them
uh getting together and talking about
business and then whatever the topics of
the day are but everybody's a little
unique and different
and it started as something we did in
covet because we would all play poker
together
and four of the poker players eventually
wound up doing this every week this
podcast
and this is in decade two of me
podcasting and so I kind of created a
format that I modeled after the
McLaughlin group
which was a Sunday Morning Show don't
know it so yeah this is Kai McLaughlin
you can look up some tapes of it anyway
this guy McLaughlin was super
cantankerous and he'd have like you know
Republican a Democrat an independent
whatever a young person a Bostonian
person a California hippie you know
whatever and he was always cantankerous
and moving the conversation along and he
would say wrong and through this and it
was like a very full contact kind of
dynamic interrupt each other
conversation but it just I was always
drew me in it's the best Sunday morning
political show of all time the
McLaughlin group and so tremath and I
had known each other from AOL he was
working at AOL when I saw my company
there the blogging company back in the
day we had met he became a venture
capitalist and then he met Mark
Zuckerberg and he was one of the first
employees at Facebook grew Facebook from
10 million to 800 million users or
something crazy like that he was
responsible for the growth team super
intelligent considered fun thoughtful
guy Dynamic aggressive and interest
great leader of people we became friends
we started playing cards together joking
laughing
and I said you know I really would like
to have you on my podcast he wanted to
be under the radar he didn't want people
to know who Jamaica was but he came on
the podcast in a lot of ways like Chris
Saka did our friend was one of the first
people I think I was one of the first
people to actually have him on a podcast
when I did my two-parter with him so
tomat became a bit of a brand after he
was on the podcast a couple times and
then he keynoted a couple of events and
we just had this Rapport and the report
came from just breaking chops and
laughing at the poker game every week
and then people saw that Rapport when we
were on stage and then he said to me one
time when he was coming out of CNBC
you know we should just do a podcast
together I was like yeah come on this
week and start up she said no no I want
to do a different type of thing just me
and you and you you know you just bring
up the news of the week I talk about it
then I ask you a question and then you
talk about it and we go back and forth
startups public markets spax public
private I was like that's a really good
idea sure let's do it um and we started
texting back before then what are you
going to call it and I said we should
give like a poker thing since it's like
poker we should call it all in
and so the two of us started doing it
but this is during covid so then we're
like well who knows about covid and
um sax had been doing a bunch of
research on and he bought ventilators
and he had masks explain who sax is so
David Sachs is an old friend of mine who
worked at PayPal with Peter Thiel went
to college with Peter Thiel he's a
republican independent really like
um chess club Debate Club brilliant
product manager created Yammer sold to
Microsoft for a billion dollars just
really smart individual but right right
leaning like seriously right leaning
like writing articles donating to people
on the right and we became close friends
our families would go on vacation
together just you know as close of
friends as you could be and
then we had him on as a guest to talk
about like hey what's going on with this
Wuhan flu thing and you know what's
going on with Trump and you know people
were very scared and confused that time
and then we had another friend who came
to Poker I didn't have a big
relationship with Freiburg every time I
was doing from poker and David Friedberg
who runs uh something called the
production board he was an early Google
employee came on and he actually is like
he created climate.com and sold that to
Monsanto so he understands science like
at a very deep level
and so all of a sudden you know this
thing clicks and then Robin Hood and
that whole AMC thing happened and I was
an investor in Robin Hood and we started
talking about that and the show just
caught Heat and the dynamic between the
four of us people really started to like
and people were at home caught heat in a
good way I think caught heat in like wow
this is really Dynamic they're smart
they're opinionated
and they're successful and so when
people see that you've made a lot of
money is one thing I learned in my life
it's like the day before the weblogs Inc
you know Sal and then the day after when
I had no money and then became a
millionaire people treated me incredibly
different
like all of a sudden I got like 30 more
IQ points and I was two feet taller I
was like I'm the same guy but like
people just take you a lot more
seriously yeah and it just is a really
good thing to understand like literally
if you
inherited a billion dollars people would
think you're a genius it's a big failing
of human nature that we have this weird
thing with the scorecard that we think
the scorecard of dollars is like
important it's not
long story short
all the stuff comes together and people
it seems to connect with people and it
starts racing up the charts
and the last couple of weeks I think
we're number 24 26 27 you know like just
top 30 podcasts in the world
Gwyneth Paltrow wrote about it in her
hoop newsletter a couple weeks ago that
she's obsessed with the podcast the
personalities and so you know this week
in startups had millions of listeners
every month and doing incredible five
days a week making millions of dollars
in advertising but it's a very Niche
thing it's just about startups so if
you're in the startup space like you
would want to take a selfie with me all
in has crossed over in a way like you
experience with the Tim Ferriss podcast
and you know people who are pursuing
Excellence it's a much wider aperture of
people yeah and so this thing just
appeals to a lot of people and it's
literally people say it's like their
Sunday morning ritual or their Saturday
morning ritual it's replaced the Sunday
morning talk show and it turns out
Politico is writing some kind of a
profile of us right now because it's
become so influential in Washington
because we talk about the economy
technology and Technologies obviously a
big impact on the economy and politics
whatever so anyway in some ways it's
become a hit uh it's very weird for me
because you know I've had a couple of
hits before but this one also is bigger
and I'm not in control of it I have
three partners and all three of my
partners on it
have never had a boss
so you've literally got four of the most
opinionated friends who've never had a
boss who have four different directions
they want to take it and it is a bit
chaotic and I'm the producer of it as
well and you know did all the work came
up with the format Etc
but objectively you know
chamoth has a series of fans freeberg
now has the stands sacks has the whole
right wing so it's like a super team has
come together yeah yeah and it's very
hard to keep a super team together for
any period of time and this thing has
come off the rails famously like two or
three times
could you walk us through your favorite
of those three times and how it was
resolved
well
I wanted to do an event because you
mentioned before I like events and I was
like let's do this all in Summit I'll do
all the work
and uh you guys show up I have a
production team
um you know here's what it will be and
one of the four of us
was in a complete panic and complaining
and arguing incessantly because he
thought I was going to ruin their
reputation because what if it's not
great
the thing comes out of the gate people
are comparing it to the Ted conference
saying this is better than recode or
better than Ted and it's the new Ted and
whatever because we got the most
incredible speakers in the world showed
up for us just everybody I invited you
you didn't make up and I'll get you next
year
I don't know if I can afford your
speaking thing
but uh if it makes you feel any better I
know I remember this and I have not done
any speaking except for South by
Southwest I want to say in three or four
years yeah
so but no there'll be some opportunity
like it'll be a fun thing for us to do
and in my own defense I have been to
events of yours before I've gone to I
have spoken with you at events so I
couldn't make that one yes you did one
of us okay all right so wait where does
the conflict come in so the conflict
came in that I just told him like Hey
listen
I'm working over here you need to shut
the [ __ ] up and let me just do my work
and stop being in a panic attack all the
time and he's like my reputation I said
yeah what if it's bad what people paid 7
500 tickets I'm like some people pay 7
500 I'll take it for every event like
it's not a big deal
and then I
um gave half the tickets for scholarship
for people
anyway we had this back and forth and
then I told the person like you know
Freeburg I was like if you don't want to
be on the show and you're complaining so
much I got Brad gerstner over here I
love how he was Anonymous up until right
now whatever the good news is Freeburg
and I after
like many friendships we
our time together but it was another one
of these like stabbed in the back
stabbing the face thing you know because
you got the quote from Doug I said
listen if you're not enjoying your time
on the all-in podcast and you don't want
to do the event why don't you do 25
episodes a year and I'll have Brad
gershner who come who sits in when one
of us is out as like the fifth Beatle
I'll have him do the other 25 we have
this big fight and the whole thing's
gonna explode and then there you know
these two are going to do their own
Pockets whatever and then we all just
sat down and we realized the audience
[ __ ] loves this we love it
let's not do any events let's not do any
spin outs yeah people wanted to do a TV
show with us you know top networks you
know all the stuff and you understand
how big the podcasting business Now is
better than anybody you know you got a
top 50 podcasts these podcasts have
become a very big business